un jour d'hiver comme un autre sous la
grisaille londonienne nous sommes à
finsbury park dans le nord de la
capitale un quartier populaire bastion
des supporters du club de foot d'arsenal
c'est ici autour de la mosquée souvent
qualifié de fondamentalistes que cette
établi une grande partie de la
communauté somalienne
ici nous sommes dans l'un des principaux
quartiers somaliens il ya beaucoup de
boutiques à un centre communautaire des
restaurants des marchés
mohamed est arrivé sur les bords de la
tamise il y à 13 ans il est aujourd'hui
l'un des porte-parole des 120 milles
somaliens installés dans la capitale
britannique la plupart d'entre eux ont
fui la guerre civile qui ravage le pays
depuis 20 ans
depuis la chute du gouvernement du
dictateur siad barré en 1991 la somalie
est en proie aux désordres politiques
économiques et sociales ce pays de la
corne de l'afrique qui a sombré dans
l'anarchie le chaos est exemple sa
situation humanitaire et sanitaire est
catastrophique le conflit a déjà fait
plus de 300 morts
tombés aux mains des fondamentalistes en
2006 la somalie est devenue le foyer
principal du terrorisme en afrique les
insurgés islamistes mènent une guerre
sans merci contre le gouvernement de
transition mis en place en 2004 en 2010
la somalie est décrétée pays le plus
dangereux de la planète
retour à londres devenue la première
ville somalienne d'europe c'est dans le
restaurant d'un compatriote que mohamed
a rendez vous avec hussein et comme
toutes les semaines c'est la guerre
civile qui est au menu
j'ai vu une mère et son enfant
explosé alors qu'il fuyait les coups de
feu
ils sont morts sous mes yeux
l'explosion les avait coupé en deux
et ça c'est quelque chose que je ne
pourrai jamais oublier quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai décidé de fuir le pays des
souvenirs d'atrocités à mogadiscio
mohamed en a plein la tête mais à
londres ces problèmes ont changé sa
nationalité et l'image de terroristes
qu'elle véhicule lui colle à la peau
résultat depuis trois ans il n'a pas vu
sa femme exil aux états unis le fbi lui
refuse un visa
si demain on divorce 1 ce ne sera pas
pour des problèmes conjugaux
divorcera parce que deux pays nous
empêche de nous retrouver pourquoi nous
ne sommes pas des criminels un combat le
terrorisme
et pourtant c'est nous qui en payons le
prix
camden au nord de londres le centre
névralgique de la communauté somalienne
c'est ici dans un centre communautaire
que travail abdul abdul est l'un des
premiers réfugiés arrivés au début des
années 90 il est aujourd'hui devenu
travailleur social
sa mission aider les nouveaux arrivants
à naviguer dans la jungle administrative
à l'époque de ce call
fardoux ça est arrivé à londres il ya
quelques mois sans un penny en poche son
mari bloqué en somalie elle doit se
débrouiller pour faire vivre ses deux
enfants pas de toit et pas d'accès aux
soins aujourd'hui l'urgence c'est la
gastro de sa petite dernière
oui s'il vous plaît je m'appelle abdul
jabbar et au centre communautaire
somaliens
j'essaie d'aider un de nos membres qui
vient juste d'avoir ses papiers
son plus jeune enfant est malade
n'a pas mangé depuis deux jours elle
vomit beaucoup
elle est dans mon bureau juste ici
elle a besoin d'être vue dès que
possible g
grâce à abdoul la petite fille sera
prise en charge dans la journée une
situation critique pour cette mère de
famille pourtant aucun regret d'avoir
quitté la somalie
quand on va faire les courses qu'on ne
sait jamais si on va rentrer vivant
les gens vivent dans la terreur
j'ai vu plein de gens morts l'a300
tellement de chance
la guerre une plaie béante qui ne se
referment jamais du coup voilà que
l'angleterre terre d'asile est devenu
depuis quelques temps le théâtre
d'affrontements ethniques pour lutter
contre ces guerres de gangs importés
d'afrique mohamed lui est devenu
conseiller auprès de la police il a un
problème avec un membre de la communauté
c'est mohamed qu'on appelle ici c'est le
médiateur
si on vient parler aux jeunes avec
quelqu'un de la communauté ça nous aide
beaucoup c'est la meilleure façon de
cris nous parce que d'habitude sans foot
pelé s'adorent ce sont ces conflits de
clans et de son clan il en existe une
quinzaine en somalie que l'on retrouve
sur le sol anglais
[Musique]
son fils était en train de se battre
avec un autre garçon somaliens
le garçon lui a planté un stylo au
dessus de la leyre et c'est ressortie de
l'autre côté
à londres les jeunes somaliens biberonné
à la guerre reproduisent
irrépressiblement des schémas violent un
phénomène qui inquiète les autorités
fin de journée sur londres mohamed part
à la recherche de brebis égarées dans
les rues de camden comme tous les jeudis
il ramène dans ses filets quelques
jeunes somaliens dans les locaux de
l'association qu'il a créée
allez les gars on monte on va discuter
mohamed a sa méthode il écoute et
devient le psy du quartier
ma question c'est quelles sont vos pires
souvenirs ici en angleterre
moi ce qui est arrivé récemment
j'ai entraîné des gamins au foot dans un
parc
est membre d'un gang nous ont attaqués
et nous ont poignardés
regardez est passé à quelques
centimètres de mon estomac est
en 2009 à londres scotland yard
comptabilisait 171 gang une vingtaine
seraient d'origine somalienne
[Musique]
mes copains avec qui jouait souvent au
foot je connaissais vraiment bien une
nuit il s'est fait poignarder il est
mort
un mec l'a tué parce qu'il n'habitait
pas le même quartier
alors qu'ils avaient tous les deux la
même culture le même pays et il l'a tuée
pour une raison tellement stupide ça m'a
choqué des problèmes d'intégration sur
lesquels la droite conservatrice
anglaise n'a pas hésité à bondir
résultat le vote d'une mesure radicale
le renvoi au pays de tous réfugiés
somaliens auteurs d'un crémant mais la
violence n'est pas la seule
l'importation des somaliens à londres
salut comment ça va le lendemain matin
mohamed nous donne rendez vous dans un
atelier de couture au sous-sol la cave
accueil des clients en vrac on vend des
vêtements et des drapeaux mais ce que
viennent chercher les initiés c'est du
khat une plante dont on mâche les
feuilles psychotropes
4 euros la botte un prix accessible à
tous mais les consommateurs de cette
plante issus d'afrique de l'est sont
principalement des hommes d'âge mûr
en général les gens lèvent la peau
regarder ça et la partie molle c'est ce
qu'il ya de meilleur
ce soir abdul notre travailleur social a
rejoint la communauté rassemblée lors
d'une soirée de lutte contre les
problèmes ethniques pour l'occasion il
est venu accompagné de ses enfants et
retrouve mohamed son vieil ami
mais avant d'assister au débat c'est
leur dis chiche à la 5ème prière de la
journée abdul et mohamed se glisse dans
une arrière-salle pour louer al
[Musique]
sur scène les représentants de la
diaspora se succèdent au rythme de
discours passionné ne suivait pas votre
ne discriminent et pas vos compatriotes
restés unis toujours avec l'honneur de
la somalie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis 20 ans les dissensions ethniques
et religieuses sont au coeur du conflit
somalien ici à londres une grande partie
de la communauté veut faire table rase
du passé
construire un futur sans répéter les
erreurs de ses aînés
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]